بكل تاكيد التاريخ له اثر فيما يتعلق
بترسيخ المؤسسه الملكيه تحدث مثلا عن
المغرب تاريخ الملكيه هو 1200 سنه والاسره
العلويه اليوم يعني منذ 1666 ميلاديه
وبالتالي هناك ثقل للمؤسسات وتقل للدوله
لانه يمكن ان تبني النظام ولكن هناك
صعوبات فيما يتعلق ببناء الدوله لنثبات
الدوله النظام يمكن ان ينهار ولكن الدوله
عندما تكون قائمه على اسس وقائمه على على
على تراث فيما يتعلق بالمؤسسات السياسيه
فانها تصمد لمده طويله تساءلت في قبل قليل
هل يمكن للملكيه ان تعود هناك تجربه مثلا
في اسبانيا كان هناك نظام الجمهوري وكانت
هناك من اسبانيا عرفت محاولات انقلابيه
منذ 1840 وكان اخرها 1985 ولكنها عادت
المؤسسه الملكيه حتى بعد نهايه الحرب
الاهليه مع مع فرانكو
فرانكو هو الذي اعاد الملكيه الى اسبانيا
والملكيه في اسبانيا التي استطاعت ان توحد
من جديد اسبانيا واستطاعت الى اليوم ان
تواجه كل تحديات انفصاليه نتذكر قبل سنوات
ما حدث في كتالونيا وكيف واجهت الحكومه
المركزيه استنادا الى ما يمنحوا الدستور
وما يثبت الوحده الوطنيه اذا هناك اشكالات
كثيره فيما يتعلق بهذا بالعوده الى تاريخ
الملكيات ومقارنتها مع الانظمه الجمهوريه
لابد ان نتذكر ان هذه الانظمه لم تستمر
فتره طويله مثلا في مصر بين 1922 1952
في ليبيا 1951 الى 1969
في اليمن
1918 الى 1962
بصفه عامه عندما نقارن زمن الملكيات في
المنطقه العربيه مقارنه مع الانظمه
الجمهوريه ان الانظمه الجمهوريه عاشت
لفتره طويله وبالتالي لم تقدم كل الاجوبه
الاقتصاديه والتنمويه والديمقراطيه فيما
يتعلق بالشعوب والانتظارات شعوب العربيه